good [ __ ] morning how's it
going guys now on this episode of living
out loud I'll show you a new intro it
doesn't really work out sounds kind of
okay but yeah you know when you become
an adult there's a couple things that
are a rite of passage it has something
to do with you drinking it
number one is dick obviously one is
alcohol and the second thing is coffee
did you guys know at a certain age if
you don't drink coffee people look at
you like you're [ __ ] insane you don't
drink coffee
yeah well [ __ ] you don't feed your kids
you don't hear me saying [ __ ] don't you
worry about while you don't wipe your
ass after you [ __ ] yeah I know that yeah
you smell let's right you stink a little
bit but do I like coffee you ask execute
now when la coffee seems to be a really
big thing I don't know when Seattle like
copies a huge thing as well but LA teams
that have this culture of like the the
new hottest like coffee shops that
people always want to go to them well
there's this coffee shop that I went to
a couple times with my friend Z and it's
a place that he always raves about they
had this drink called system midnight
now I don't know it's not a joke to why
he you know gave to me but you know
[ __ ]
why are you gonna stay like that you
looking at that coffee like he's a dick
but the system in life from graffiti is
probably one of my favorite coffee
drinks ever is mocha e cinnamon the
delicious see you stupid use make up
words e now the thing about graffiti is
when you walk in if [ __ ] looks like a
scene out of the matrix
it's all white and black everything's
super Art Deco they got the suave ass
Mexican dude in the back he looked like
you try to [ __ ] somebody would you that
coffee better because I'm trying to [ __ ]
you know I like graffitis ambiance and
she said I grew up kind of you know poor
so when you have that type of mentality
you walk into a place like that I feel
like I'm a streak stain on underwear now
of course when I went to go get coffee I
went to go to copy with edrick as well
places to finish it up with his own
tongue still saying loose [ __ ] you
[ __ ] swine now as I mentioned in a
previous vlog before you guys already
know that Educare is a musician he's a
dope bass rapper but what you guys don't
know he's also very into fashion dude
came to drink coffee and he look like
Laurence Fishburne and the matrix but
the person that was probably the most
excited to see was his girl amen
aka Amen today now Amen is a friend that
I got to meet through Z and if you've
never had the opportunity to meet her
what you did it because I'm talking
about in the video but this woman is
like a ray of African sunshine what is
wrong with a roach in bacteria told me
to just go you can
you know when you meet somebody and you
know perfect that you were gonna buy
with them super well amen is that woman
just here on
where if you check right now the Sun is
clearly out but there's not that many
people copy those like a socializing
community that I really enjoy and it
seems to be a huge part of LA culture
coffee I feel like for the majority of
people in LA it's more of a social thing
like people just go get coffee to
socialize if you want to get out of the
house you're not really hungry you don't
want to grab something to eat and going
to a coffee shop and talking to your
friends it's probably one of the more
enjoyable things to do out here you know
obviously a lot of you out there you
know get hookers and smoke crack and
whatever but that ain't me I don't smoke
crack I'm too fat